[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
welcher vor kurzem eine e-mail bekommen
und war wurde ich zum web video preis
nominiert und war das erste mal dieses
jahr gibt's nämlich zum ersten mal die
kategorie food und ich denke doch meine
zuschauer da meine videos eingereicht
haben und wir jetzt noch mit nominiert
sind ja murat die definition wer gleich
gekommen erklärte der web video preis
ist der bedeutendste medienpreis in
europa hat nicht mit dem preis im
internet frei internet also vergleichbar
mit einer ehrenurkunde der
bundesjugendspiele 19.700 so ungefähr
nur und bisschen bisschen wertvoller
ja und ich muss ehrlich so zu sagen ich
hätte irgendwie gar nicht damit
gerechnet habe dass aber auch gar nicht
ausscheren und umso mehr haben wir uns
natürlich darüber gefreut dass wir
nominiert wurden
und ja der preis dann wurde dieses jahr
in düsseldorf im dom übergeben und es
waren 3800 zuschauer mit dabei 3800
gäste und ich muss dazu sagen ich war
sehr aufgeregt denn ich weiß es nicht
weil man hat ja nicht in der hand also
frau meinen videos oder auch wenn ich
auch messe bin bin ich normalerweise nie
aufgeregt weil ich immer weiß wenn was
schiefgeht dann findet morath immer im
passenden spruch oder auch ich selber
und dann kann ich das immer alles gerade
wegen aber da hat man einfach nicht in
der hand und deswegen ja war schon die
aufregung bisschen tage ja bei dir nicht
aber bei mir beim werfen und ein tag hat
bei uns ziemlich früh begonnen und ihr
dürft jetzt einfach mal zu schauen wir
sind nämlich ganz früher mit unserem
team nach düsseldorf gefahren
und was ist mit diesem einhorn neben mir
auf sich hat erfahrt ihr am ende genau
ihre seite haben wir gegen die erste
station war über einen maler und
tapezierer hh oder lustlos
[Musik]
samira dem heutigen termin bei euch zum
schminken
[Musik]
in der
jetzt immer alle angezogen warten noch
auf die letzten team mitglieder
da hat sich schon wie elefanten
anführerin versteckt und jetzt fahren
wir mit dem auto direkt zum lohn und da
bin ich schon erwartet und wir sind
natürlich auch direkt also die ganze
zeit immer ging es eigentlich aber jetzt
noch vor dir das im park schon ziemlich
aufgeregt und gespannt
angemeldet war mir roddick und ihn
bereit und wir werden die gleichen abend
holt und ein kuscheltier braucht gerecht
und erste mal bin ich aufgeregt und von
mir ab
daher hab ich kopfweh und komplette wenn
moment naja wir tragen
[Musik]
wir gehen
viele gesagt 3800 gäste sind heute da
und hallo wie geht es dir
er zeigt uns finden es denn aufgeregt
warum jetzt weiter nicht so viele leute
da und man hat mir nicht in der hand ich
hab' ich gewinne und aufgeregt bist du
ein bisschen preis kann ich die sofort
die angst leben ist wie ein wohnzimmer
feeling wir sind alle freunde und
familie klassentreffen abitur aber alle
haben eins bekommen
im grunde perfekt okay dann jetzt ist
die aufregung weg danke sehr kurz und
irgendwelche kategorien nominiert in der
kategorie food sind ja 25 kategorien
insgesamt wurde so was überrascht dass
dominiert wird weil ich glaube die
kategorie zertifikat ab jetzt ganz neu
die gab es letztes jahr noch nicht es
war auch sehr überrascht ich denke dass
meine zuschauer wahrscheinlich auch mit
eingereicht haben dafür bin ich sehr
dankbar
und jetzt vor ort verzehrt wird
insgesamt kannst du schätzen die viele
leute wie viel videos eingereicht wurden
fast so ungefähre früher gar nicht gerne
zahl 1 505 der einreichung bernd stolle
hohe zahl
es sind ganz genau genommen 31 1724
einreichung so viele videos wahnsinn ist
alles irgendwie blockiert werden
angeschaut werden kategorisiert werden
also diese ganzen videos habe ich
alleine geguckt
deswegen wird auch so weiter hat die
academy sich durch geguckt und das
nochmals an dieser stelle nochmals
kompliment für so eine große arbeit
heißt du bist das erste mal
ich bin das erste mal mit dabei ersten
mal hier und das erste mal auch
nominiert du bist ich versuchte mit
einer schauspielerin zu vergleichen mehr
als männlich würde ich sagen
christoph faisst content und wird
wahrscheinlich ab
aber wir haben schön dass du da bist
gibt es in die was bedeutete in der
wahrscheinlich schon etwas mal zugeguckt
der web video preis ich habe ja schon
gesagt ist so etwas wie sein wohnzimmer
feeling was bedeutet so eine nominierung
sagen dieses jahr wiesen zuschauerpreis
wird der anerkannte was man tut was man
jeden tag leistet und er macht die
arbeit die man immer hineingesteckt und
deswegen schon eine schöne anerkennung
und auch einen dank des zuschauer andrej
youtube oder an die artisten und
ansonsten ja ich freue mich echt gehört
auch dazu
wenn du gewinnen würdest du dann
irgendwie vielleicht ein webvideo preis
kuchen oder ein gericht erfinden können
ja das kann ich auf jeden fall machen
meine doch jetzt auch mit dabei und die
hoffnung gesagt mama wenn du gewinnst
ich freue mich dann mit an und da hab
ich dann mit ihr auf die bühne und dann
natürlich mit mir den kuchen backen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind jetzt hier ausgelassen hier im
internet geben und fotos gemacht so oft
gefehlt
mit roten blauen wirklich gelaufen und
dann muss man wirklich von rechts nach
links arbeiten und lange gefragt ob
fotos machen anderen verändertes mit
prima über in den vip bereich
da werden dann auch von murat und samira
auf mich natürlich immer wieder wissen
und richter kann ich von meiner familie
dürfen und dann geht die veranstaltung
demnächst auch schon los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
jetzt ist der blaue teil modus zu ende
und jetzt gehen alle mal gespannt wie es
aussieht
wieder genesen
davon ist dr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe mir von der kamera aufgestellt
[Musik]
ich bin ja auch studierte soziologin und
deswegen weiß ich natürlich das was sich
in der gesellschaft food das zeigt sich
dann auch ganz schnell im netz also
alles was ein trend ist in der
gesellschaft kommt natürlich ins netz
und war ganz schnell und deswegen gibt's
im netz ganz ganz viel was sich um essen
dreht es geht um mut und deswegen haben
uns gedacht da muss eine neue kategorie
zu diesem thema geben
wut und auf mich sehr gefreut hat bei
den nominierten zu sehen im fernsehen
wird sehr viel gekocht aber nie gegessen
da wird gekocht und gegessen hier denn
unsere vorschläge in der kategorie food
[Applaus]
[Musik]
natürlich die schwaben vorher eingesetzt
im reigen von allen seiten dass marin 2
[Applaus]
fertiger krustenbraten wie geile
kommentieren einfach aufhören
das gefällt mir
bei gucken wer es geschafft hat hier als
gewinner vom feld zu gehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und jetzt von der wahrscheinlich besten
menschlichen kaffeemaschine
hallo
[Musik]
hallo hallo herzlich willkommen kommt zu
uns ich stelle mich mal hier zu euch
warte mal hierhin so wen hast du uns
denn damit gebracht
ja das ist die familie und die ist auch
schon seit fünf jahren mit dabei war
eineinhalb jahre alt als ich mit dem
fußball angefangen habe ich hab damals
noch lehramt studiert den grund und
hauptschullehrerin und mir war
anscheinend langweilig neben haushalts
beruf kind ehemann
das ist ein kind ist mein quartier nicht
ausgelesen
der trend geht zum eigenen kind wir in
der orf- schlamm und und das heißt
sommer was die mama kocht schmeckt das
wirklich gut oder sieht das nur toll aus
schmeckt auch gut was kann sie am besten
zirkon schokokuchen ich bin wurde
freundschaft befragt was du tatsächlich
am allerbesten kampf gibt es irgendwas
wo du sagst ja da bin ich wirklich
spitze
ich denke beim motiv torten finde ich da
kam kurz dem krieg schnell die motive
hast du gemacht
auch schon ganz ganz viele die letzte
weiße mit baby shower torte an die
antwort für meine nachbarn im display
bekommt und hatte auch ganz fies aber
auch ganz viel herzhaftes essen gibt bei
mir also immer abwechslungsreich also
hier nehmen uns feder der kollege hat
rita du bist der weltmeister unter den
tarif dass du nach den besten kaffee hat
die kapelle in düsseldorf kannst du auch
kunst auf dem kaffee machen
also ich meine du lachst jetzt
wahrscheinlich wenn ich sage kannst du
mir ein herz fließen
eine palme für dich für mich ja okay
dann komme ich ja auch zugleich ich
überlege mir noch eine frage für dich
wartet
berlin passau heute abend wenn du mal
auf die community guckst auf die leute
alle die hier sitzen
was würdest du hier heute abend zum
essen anbieten gleich auf der after show
party natürlich schokokuchen ja von mir
als lieblings pure mehr grün und
ansonsten ganz viele tolle vorspeise
hauptspeise ich hoffe es gibt auch was
im alle noch ziemlich hunger der schweiz
damit im frühjahr noch die kleinigkeit
für euch zubereitet
bist du immer dabei wenn die mama dreht
aber so versuchte es möglich zu machen
oder ok dann wünsche ich dir alles gute
gratuliere dir wahnsinnig haben wir den
ball schon übergeben januar hätte den
preis und empfängern facebook selber den
hin ins aber natürlich in die küche da
wo er hingehört okay gut und jetzt
verraten mit drehzahlen die schmeckten
kaffee ob mit oder ohne palme mit oder
ohne palme wie schmeckt sein café ich
meine es ist ein ganz besonderer kaffee
das überlasse ich bin okay bis dahin
dann gratuliere ich euch und wünsche
euch eine schöne haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein
mit gefiebert von ihrer mutter auch ganz
lange geduldig sitzen aber
zurückgeklappt werden wir haben wir
freuen uns riesig und samira glaube ich
auf alle allermeisten wird wollen sogar
ganz kurz geweint vor lauter freude hat
sie gesagt
da drücken das steht nimmt die mama oma
die haben heute zum ersten mal entdeckt
und die hat den preis nämlich bekommen
den web video preis für den besten live
stream und ich bin total geplättet weil
ja weil es einfach vor zuckersüße comic
jemand zur oma ok marmeladen oma genau
am laden und jannik mir heute leider das
erste mal sogar ein bisschen glück und
gefühl dass ich dann total verrückt ich
hätte nie gedacht dass wir in jedem fall
der video preis neu bin ich habe den
letztes jahr über das handy geschaut und
jetzt bin ich hier versuche einfach
verrückt wirklich toll vor allem die
leistung gemacht wirklich jede woche
jeden samstag einen live stream um 20
uhr und sacken natürlich alle fleißig
einschalten jetzt wissen wir auch die
ganze familie
was für jeden samstag um 20 uhr schauen
wir auf facebook oder youtube auf
youtube genau auf mich und was macht ihr
da ganz genau damit wären vorstellen
kann
also werden wir lesen vor
er macht die video und ich erzähle meine
geschichte aus meiner kindheit
ja wir euch über leute sehr interessant
ist geld bin 85 krieg erlebt und so
weiter sehr sehr etwa seinen verlieren
seite und jetzt machen wir noch etwas
15 drehte am tag und jeden einzelnen
jeden menschen ist so angenommen sind so
viel bewirken können
es gibt uns auf sie zurück richtig toll
vielen dank vielleicht habt ihr auch mal
etwas gemeinsam zu machen könnt ihr eure
gesichter oder sucht eine geschichte
erzählen und ich pack wasser und dann
können wir euch gerne in unserer küche
einladen wirklich soll
dankeschön und herzlichen glückwunsch
der web video preis und ich muss dazu
sagen wenn man es natürlich sehr gefreut
familie hat kurz vorher noch geweint und
habe gesagt mama guck mal der mut immer
noch nicht aufgerufen werden verloren
gehe und sanierer komcom ist ein halb
soviel kategorien und kurz darauf kam
dann schon die kategorie aber sie musste
halt wirklich über zwei stunden still
sitzen bleiben und das war natürlich
nicht so einfach aber am ende hat mich
sehr gefreut jeder und vor lauter
aufregung tag davor kann sich mit dem
mikrofon gemalt was sie natürlich ein
richtig cooles ereignis und höhepunkt
für mich muss ich sagen war die
marmeladen oma ich habe vorher noch nie
von marmeladen oma gehört und vom
yannick und das fand ich echt zog es sie
hat er den preis gewonnen für den besten
live stream und danach haben wir auch
dann mal ihre videos angeschaut und
familie hat mir total gemacht und ist
auch gleich jeden abend herzlich
gratuliert der vfb ski und die jungs von
der gsoa 60er die waren echt lieber
mensch muss alles auf den newton dazu
bei die machen wirklich was ganz ganz
los wie der ira hat auch die macht
gleich aufgezogen jedoch also schaut man
die größe an
kämmerer laden ohne ganz ganz tolle
geschichte war und auch die attentäter
waren echt sie waren echt am programm zu
lebt ja also die preisverleihung war
echt super
ich wollte eigentlich auf der bühne noch
was sagen aber muss sozusagen barbara
schöneberger hatte bisher viel geredet
liebe barbara ich finde ich super nett
und du bist echt eine klasse frau aber
dürfen ja ich wollte nämlich dazu sagen
es war natürlich eine super show und es
ist auch wirklich ganz ganz toll für uns
youtuber sage ich jetzt auch mal dafür
ausgezeichnet zu werden
aber man darf auch nicht vergessen es
wurde nämlich mehrfach betont dass es
eben toll ist
heutigen zeit wenn man ein talent hat
dass man das sofort mit allen teilen
kann und dass man wirklich super berühmt
werden kann
aber man muss auch dazu sagen dass der
weg bis dahin wirklich nicht immer
einfach ist und es ist nicht einfach so
das talent genügt das heißt man braucht
viele durchhaltevermögen viel
durchsetzungsvermögen zu sehen viel
disziplin man muss auch freizeit
verzichten ist alles super viel
mitarbeit viel mit zeit verbunden und es
ist eben doch nicht so ganz einfach wie
es aussieht und was ich immer sage auch
auf messen wenn ich da bin und viele
viele kleine kinder auch vor mir stehen
oder jugendliche die sagen mensch ich
möchte später mal reich und berühmt
werden am besten werde ich youtube muss
ich immer sagen es ist eben doch nicht
so einfach und es ist viel wichtiger
dass ihr eine ausbildung machen studium
macht egal was hauptsache ihr habt noch
in der tasche und einen youtube atting
könnt ihr immer noch nebenher machen
genau ich bin doch weiß werden ohne
youtube und vor allem kann man auch
glücklich werden oder youtube also wir
zwar hätten auch ein glückliches leben
ohne youtube
aber so haben jetzt einfach ein anderes
glückliches leben ja gut im auto zu
sagen
der hund freut gab ihr freund sich die
skripte ja doch wollen wir unbedingt zu
sagen dass man auch sehr wichtig und das
ist immer so und frenetisch wurde jetzt
zum fertigen bekundet es ist was es ja
zum pferd im hintergrund also nach
dieser show gab es natürlich auch eine
after show party und die after show
party war wirklich sehr lustig wir
müssen uns übrigens bald spülmaschine
wollen die nicht ab aber egal
ja die war sehr lustig da war noch alle
gäste mit dabei und die party die war
gespannt zum auto also nicht unser video
ist von otto gespannt was soll man die
party war gesponsert steht auch auf dem
pferd auto okay es ist ein fertig
gerettet es ist ein einhorn und ja da
waren ein paar einhörner im umlauf und
sie und viele energy drinks ist mal
wieder ein hotel ich ja sagen wir mal so
und wir haben dann gedacht also murat
hat es genauso wir müssen das einhorn
retten und hat es ein hohn entführt
campino ist haben sich immer mehr
menschen brauchen ja und wir hätten dann
hin und her und hin und her und dann
tagt der rat die das können wir nicht
zulassen dass ein hund braucht ein
zuhause wir nehmen uns einfach mit
und dann hat es neben den hackern
gestellt das war der türsteher dort und
hat verkörpern egara fotos bewacher
dieses einhorn und beschützte es mit
seinem leben das er da hat man dann auch
gemacht ihren dank der fähren und
einfach im monat zugegangen ist einfach
- mit gegangen ja nachts um 2 durch
düsseldorf
dann stand plötzlich im parkhaus und ist
ein hund war dann plötzlich im
kofferraum nach hause fährt geklaut
du hast mich geklaute beschleunigt
werden gleichwohl wurde kürzlich von
autos wirklich laut geklatscht
sie applaudieren kollisionen ein paar
klassiker alleine
was macht es ein hund hat mich einfach
damit wir noch geklaut nehmen eben mit
schlimmen folgen passiert dass wir am
nächsten morgen in düsseldorf mit einem
einhorn im kofferraum aufgewacht sind
und es hat den weg nach war kein so
gefunden
und ich habe angst dass mich die kameras
aufgenommen haben habe ich mein recht
veröffentlicht dann hat man mehr
entschuldigt ich hatte damals gewesen
und die haben hat mir geantwortet und
sie haben dem einhorn und gutes zuhause
geben kennt und gut genug zu essen
bekommt und ja das haben sich cool
reagiert also die ganze community die
leute nichts gelesen haben von dem
echten hattrick und und ich habe mich
dann noch mal ich hab dann mit ihren
nochmals telefoniert hat mich nochmal
bei den entschuldigt und die fand mit
ganz ganz lustig muss sagen und jetzt
ammann ein hund zu hause und wir haben
schon fährst ja wir haben so ein pferd
und samira sagt über mama hatte dass ein
hund weg in mein zimmer ist das freud
ist kein pferdestall hier für und dann
haben wir uns gedacht dass jemand von
euch das einhorn bekommt und zwar würden
wir es gerne unter allen von zuschauern
verloren
ihr könnt ihr einfach eine frage stellen
ich muss dazu sagen ich muss es einfach
noch ein bisschen referieren es soll ja
daran hat ihn mitgenommen
jetzt also klingt ja alles beschweren
ich werde vom wissen reparieren ich
glaube es tut mir noch ein einhorn zur
verfügung stellen ich hoffe dass mir das
zu schicken jetzt jetzt bekommen sie ein
intaktes und als trotzdem schossen
referiert vielleicht auch zwei verloren
und ist die preisfrage als er beschwert
euch nicht ihr wisst ja angesehen
geister und welche smartphone schärfen
jetzt kommst du preisfrage oder eine
preisfrage weniger
einfache wie viel firma hat 1 1 vom
platz
das war so das ist eine fernseh frage
alles war sein erster vertrag hat das
machen wir nicht auf einem kanal eine
eigene steuer sind ja häufig sogar
gestellt wie es mir was wie hoch genau
aber wir fragen einfach wir sagen
einfach warum möchtest genau du dies ist
ein horn gewinnen und dann schauen wir
mal was sie schreiben
ok und dann wird das ganze per zufall
angebot so machen wir das und das finde
ich auch richtig cool
ja ich denke ich sollte mich noch bei
euch bedanken vielen dank für den sektor
erwartet gelaufen das freut mich
wirklich sehr gut zu machen die cenit
schweiz ag verwies in seiner gemeinde
vielen dank dafür und war wirklich eine
super erfahrung und hat uns auch sehr
viel spaß gemacht da mit dabei zu sein
und ja wir freuen uns aufs nächste jahr
möchte er wieder nominiert und zwar
wiederum laufen überall also viel spaß
noch an ihren schönen tag noch
morgen gibt wieder ein rezept video
werden die tolle torte und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wird dann siehst du es
machen kann
neben e mail maschine
den hat auch gesagt als das iphone
mitgenommen
[Musik]
mit